the consequence of a delusion the
breakdown that follows after truth is
revealed that person's gonna do well in
life
imagine being his parents I'd make a
joke but I feel sorry for them it's a
breakdown which you also see on social
media where celebrities resort to all
caps insanity and response to cheeky
memes remember this one Trump just
reposted it prompting Bette Midler to
scream frantically you think this is a
joke don't you
it's not he means it he will change the
rules and his enablers will let him if
he wins again he will rule you until he
dies you die or both then you get Ivanka
if you're lucky of course that's a joke
but maybe not at least Ivanka is saying
Midler is so nutty elephants keep trying
to eat her meanwhile after Trump's
presser CNN goes full Freudian this was
a very disturbing tableau for the
country it was dark because he's made
clear that his mind is dark this is
somebody in deep psychological distress
right now self pitying insecure angry
that's a straight news reporter right
once again CNN's very best become
psychiatrist diagnosing mental illness
no surprise since Hartwood is a paranoid
narcoleptic who eats his own air I'm
kidding but see anyone can play doctor
especially in times of hysteria when you
see someone else's good time as your bad
emotion fuels the anger the media gins
it up for ratings making The Hangover
worse once the fantasy collapses it
happened before righteous rage followed
by depression and it'll happen again but
remember the meeting the Dems resorted
to similar to attacks on Reagan Bush
McCain Bork and yes even poor MIT the
dog abuser but the attacks on Trump are
more plentiful and more intense why is
that because he fought back remember
when people mocked Trump defenders who
would say but he fights hell they were
right it's why he's winning and why the
other side keeps screaming
dan I have a theory that you should only
tweets in all caps if your house is on
fire I just mean you shouldn't even be
on Twitter yeah obviously for people
that are on Twitter a lot they they
think that they're having an impact but
it really is like there's talking to
themselves
he's like spitting in the wind yeah and
it goes away so quickly so it's kind of
pointless the other thing it's rude
spitting in the wind Dana it's a family
show if you spit in the wind sometimes
it comes back to you in the face exactly
it's an apt analogy like Bernie fights
yes right Bernie bites exactly yeah he's
not gonna he's not gonna take these Iowa
right results lying down mm-hmm mm-hmm I
take a lot of things lying down Lawrence
because I'm lazy let me ask you did you
see that what did you think of that
video of that kid that the creepiest
raising like it's I thought it was funny
and then I look at it I go there's what
is wrong with these people in college
well I covered college for two years at
campus reform and this is typical
behavior that these people and this is
part of the professor's for fall fall as
well because you know we think the other
side just have I think one has bad ideas
but I love one we can go I have a drink
and everything they're being talked at
the other side on college campuses or
evil yeah that that you that they're a
threat to democracy that they're a
threat to the country and so when you
have these developing minds that should
be learning both sides of the political
spectrum and you in you put that
nonsense in their head they just start
reacting like that you know what I heard
on something - we don't know yeah I
heard that that kid want is actually now
getting a job at CNN as a media reporter
could be or maybe it'll replace you I
don't know what do you think me though
that I mean that's crazy to extrapolate
from what that's this bad behavior and
that clearly threatening I would if the
police are aware of it they should be
checking him out yeah drugs may be an
issue but you can't extrapolate from
there so that's typical behavior
oncology if you took an example of a
right-wing or saying something crazy and
said by all Republicans are all
considered say no that's not fair he's a
trend 103 examples yeah so to me the the
big news here it seems to me look Trump
and people who would
are upset and I think lots of Democrats
are upset at the idea that there was a
power play that was devoid of paying
attention to what was going on that you
had Republicans and say yeah he did
something wrong but we don't want to
impeach him it's like people just are
lacking in saying conviction and holding
to the promise to uphold the
Constitution all right they just don't
want to gotta move on to the next we're
gonna move on to the next step in this
which is the next impeachment MO Emily
the thing that drives me crazy is the
diagnosis when people diagnose people's
problems
I mean you know the doctors aren't
allowed to do that without seeing a
patient but Harwood is mm-hmm I agree
also that video of that guy at ASU
that's my entire metaphor for the
Democratic Party right now which is that
the Democratic Party leadership are
screaming in the middle of their echo
chamber they are fueled entirely by
emotion and contempt and that's one of
the Four Horsemen right remember this
John Gottman saying once you have
contempt like the whole world is over
there's no you can't proceed with logic
anymore and meanwhile while this guy is
is like literally going crazy screaming
at what he thinks is so true all around
him is everyone I gotta get to class in
about 20 minutes I'm videotaping this
insane guy like what am I having for
dinner I gotta do this because meanwhile
we have all these statistics that came
out that was covered in the State of the
Union I mean the Dow has been up almost
60% this is the election SP almost
fifty-six percent ninety percent of
Americans are satisfied with their
personal life these are things that
don't matter so literally the rest of
the party is watching the leadership in
the middle go beside themselves and make
no production whatsoever and at the end
of the day we're gonna learn at the
ballot box who made the most sense to
them it's not Pelosi yeah well let me
just tell you is like what is it eighty
percent of Americans are represented by
the senators who voted to convict and
remove this president hey well you know
it didn't work out